may the force be with us may the force
be with us yes I can't imagine how you
felt saying that hey I have to say it
was one of those moments that I was
really nervous oh four weeks before and
I kept us walking around my house just
trying out the line so just be in the
bathroom and we like may the force be
with you may the force be with you may
the force be with you you know that you
go over and over and over again because
I knew it was such a momentous moment
what do you think about the theory that
Jen is raised mom just because they both
have brown hair doesn't really relate to
I rebell Star Wars is really embracing
these lead female characters which we
had not had before have you had the
chance to talk with you know Carrie
Fisher Daisy Ridley about being a female
in this universe in this it's just it's
just a fantastic time and rather than it
being a trend or being something unusual
I would hope that we're in a world now
where we have an equal amount of male
leads and equal amount of females in
burbs absolutely how it should be rogue
one a Star Wars story hits theaters
December 2016
you